for the first time for over four years
nato's most powerful member has a leader
who is
firmly convinced of the value of the
alliance
we do not view nato as a sort of a
protection racket we believe that
nato is vital to our ability to maintain
american security uh
um for the next uh next remainder of the
century
when nato was founded in 1949 it had a
clear mission
waging what became known as the cold war
and making sure it didn't become a hot
one
after the fall of the berlin wall nato
troops were deployed to try and hold the
peace and the balkans
and then in 2003 they radically changed
their mission
and sent troops to afghanistan in nato's
founding treaty
the key clause is article 5 which says
an attack on any member state
is an attack on all the nato countries
it's only been invoked once in 2001
after 9 11. this year nato allies were
given no choice but to follow
president biden's decision and pull out
of afghanistan
but they know the taliban are emboldened
and there's a considerable fear of what
comes next
there will be a power vacuum there will
be a tussle for power
between the current government the
taliban
other groups such as isis that are
forming and of course that is going to
cause
a huge amount of instability lots of
sadly civilian casualties and of course
a spillover into the region and perhaps
internationally with terrorism
and so all of that is going to reflect
very badly
on the long-term reputation of nato
nato now has to find a role in a
multi-polar world
with china and once again russia seen as
its main adversaries
but there's little doubt its mission in
afghanistan has left its resolve
somewhat diminished and its reputation
more than a little damaged
james bay's al jazeera london
very pleased to welcome alexander
verschbo to al jazeera distinguished
fellow at the atlantic council
but also a former deputy secretary
general to nato
and a former u.s ambassador to the
military alliance with us from
philadelphia great pleasure to have you
with us
sir just from the outset it must have
just been a relief
for all the other nato members to see
joe biden turn up i mean okay obviously
they knew he was coming but they just
know that it's going to be a it's going
to be a smoother ride
yeah that's certainly the case uh we
have a president who really believes in
nato
who speaks in a polite and friendly way
to his fellow allies doesn't bully them
so
uh breath of fresh air from the allied
point of view has it been a good nato
summit for
for joe budden i was saying to a
correspondent earlier how he wanted
china front and center and that has been
the biggest thing to come out of the the
communique
yes i agree uh i think he got more than
he even may have expected from this nato
summit
because there are some differences at
least a difference of emphasis among
allies on
whether china is really a threat or
whether it's a more manageable
challenge compared to russia but he did
get some strong language
on china on the systemic challenge that
it poses to the rules-based
international order
and he did get agreement to pursue an
agenda that's very forward-looking
which in its different components will
also deal with
with those challenges from china whether
it's new technologies
nuclear buildup of cyber attacks
uh the agenda for nato 2030 as was
adopted at this uh summit
is uh directed against everybody but it
has a lot of relevance for the china
challenge
it's their the possibility though the
risk even of getting too focused on
china
and russia for that matter i know they
are perceived as the biggest threats for
nato but there's a whole lot of other
stuff
and other issues within the nato family
which need to be sorted out
oh yes has more than its fair share of
challenges
including some internal ones but i think
that uh
on russia the language is strong but
it's
appropriately strong because russia has
been really a revisionist
aggressive power since it invaded
ukraine in 2014
and it's shown absolutely no sign of
backing away
from its disruptive posture so
this summit gives joe biden a
strong boost as he goes into his meeting
with vladimir putin
on wednesday in geneva showing that the
alliance is united
uh behind its founding values and
by a strong commitment to defend itself
and to protect neighboring states
including ukraine
and georgia on china i think it's
stronger than expected but i think it's
it's balanced i think those allies who
still want to cooperate with china
uh have something to show for it in
terms of
the readiness of nato to engage with
china not just confront china
so all things taken together i think uh
it's a good result for both sides of the
atlantic
just something uh completely different
as they say and that is climate change
interesting that nato put that on its
agenda this year and zero for the for
the 2030
uh agenda and said we want to be the
leading body
in the world when it comes to the
effects of climate change on security
that's a very ambitious and i think nato
knows that
it's not going to be the first responder
in terms of the broader
climate change agenda but there is a
strong military dimension to climate
change in terms of
its effect on military infrastructure
and operations
and nato i think is claiming the
responsibility to fully assess and
understand
these risks and also be a leader in
mitigating
the direct risks of militaries on the
climate
so going towards green military vehicles
and
uh more green practices by
nato's militaries and propagating the
the know-how in that regard
i think is a reasonable role it's not
it's not the central role but it's an
important role
interesting stuff isn't it ambassador
alexander verschbo now with the atlantic
council a pleasure talking to you
thank you for your time thank you
and a reminder we're waiting to hear
from joe biden the stage is set there as
it has been
for some time he had a long meeting with
turkish president recep tayyip erdogan
who recently finished his news
conference we will bring you joe biden's
address to the nato summit or his news
conference at the nato summit
live on al jazeera when it happens